una piedra que crea controversia la
piedra de escón conocida también como
piedra del destino llegó a la abadía de
West para la coronación de Carlos III el
emblemático artefacto es un símbolo
sagrado escocés sobre el que Los
Monarcas han sido coronados durante
siglos bueno por supuesto al estar la
piedra Aquí hay una sensación de unidad
real hay una gran historia detrás de
esto que comenzó con un poco de
enemistad y luego la difunta reina la
trajo de regreso a Escocia en un acto de
bondad en 1996 y se presenta como un
símbolo de unidad de amistad y parte de
la contribución de Escocia a la
coronación la piedra fue trasladada
desde su habitual morada el castillo de
edimburgo por primera vez desde hace 25
años
[Música]
es un momento maravilloso y bastante
complicado tenemos integrantes del
personal que trabajaban aquí cuando la
piedra se fue en 1996 y recordamos eso
el origen de la piedra es desconocido
pero se cree que se usó en la toma de
posesión de Los Reyes escoceses desde
principios del siglo ix en 1296 el rey
Eduardo I de Inglaterra arrebató la
piedra a los escoceses y en 1308 la
incorporó a la silla de coronación en la
abadía de Westminster Desde esa época la
silla se ha utilizado en las ceremonias
de coronación de Monarcas ingleses y
británicos desde Enrique IV en 1399 los
preparativos para la coronación del
nuevo rey y el próximo 6 de mayo en la
abadía de westmins Van viento en popa
con tradiciones que se remontan a unos
mil años